so
with the master p thing you were around
master p
kind of in the peak of no limit right
towards probably towards the yeah it was
about the peak yeah 99 was the peak yeah
um you're playing football in
new orleans um
you had to be around some crazy [ __ ]
i was you know i was you know they so
they were
there their compound all their stuff was
down in baton rouge which was about 60
miles from
from new orleans um but yeah i was down
there and it was
it was crazy it was just so it was just
so dynamic you know
like we i was down there one time and
they assigned this um basketball player
from
wnba and she you know she would mess
around on the on the beat machine
and they were just messing around they
went in there and they they recorded
hoodie who like like just
just just sitting out like in the studio
like this hanging out
and she just was messing around they're
like hey let's go in the studio and the
dudes just showed up they were in the
studio all night and came out with us
man that was my [ __ ] i was off the true
to the game [ __ ] the true album it was
like that where
it was just people coming together like
talking getting them recordings
that's why they were putting out albums
every two weeks they were so many
everybody had a [ __ ] album
wait so hooty who was helped produced by
a wnba player yes
holy sh who what do you know remember i
don't remember her name but i i was
not even that good yeah i mean that's
[ __ ] crazy
so it was live like that and then you
know they go to lsu
um down the road shoot basketball it was
and it felt like a family it really felt
like a family
yes he murdered silk that's they're all
brothers so you know yeah
that's crazy man how long were you
actually like how long was master p
your agent how long did it last
about a year it was about a year and you
realize like oh man
well the agency just started to it
started to fall apart you know i
i think and you know kind of my fault
because
i think if i had taken their idea of the
contract and become the highest paid
player
that would have looked better for an
agent right no and i think it could have
turned into something more but
we got so much negative publicity and
negative media coverage
that it wasn't the story wasn't you know
rebellious upstart
you know you know pushes back against
agents it was look what these you know
look what happens when you hire a rapper
to represent you
right